well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages in the next half hour we
will see what's making the headlines
with the columnist and broadcaster steve
richards and the former
government special adviser salma shah
great to see both of you
um front pages though before we chat the
metro then declaring freezy does it in
response to the lowering
of the covert alert level and the
forthcoming relaxation of restrictions
the telegraph quotes the prime minister
insisting it's up to all of us to
exercise common sense
here's the ice headline six days it says
until you can
hug your family daily mail now
the end is now in sight
well the sun's priorities appear to be
focused on staying in as they exclaim
oh dear yes yes yes you can read that
yourself yorkshire post gives most of
its front page to the easing of
restrictions
as well ahead of the queen's speech
tomorrow the mirror leads on one
family's plea to the prime minister to
fix adult social care which
johnson pledged to do back in 2019
labour has patronized its heartland
voters for too long that's according to
the party's deputy leader angela rainer
who was spoken exclusively to the
guardian financial times leading with
the price of iron ore hitting an
all-time high so let's talk more then
steve richard salma shah are here
welcome salma let's kick off with the
daily mail shall we um
the prime minister the end is now in
sight this is
in a sense for the scientists the scary
bit isn't it
well yes because the whole idea of this
unlocking has been based on
doing things um steadily within uh
data not dates is the prime minister's
favorite saying
and so we're going to see you know what
this next stage is going to bring in
terms of
you know any spikes in cases but i think
across
all the coverage what we're going to see
is a lot of relief and a lot of um
sort of upbeat tone uh because we're all
feeling it
clearly um and it does feel like you
know it's going to come to an end soon
notwithstanding the fact that there
still could be issues particularly
around
travel over the summer how do you think
people will feel about
this this idea that the one metre plus
rule could be axed which is something
the daily mails picked up on
um no mosques in schools which maybe
gave some reassurance
to some parents you know the fact that
some people have to ease themselves out
of this which has been months and months
now hasn't it steve
yeah i think that's an interesting point
i think some people will
struggle with the easing of restrictions
in the same way that many
have struggled with the continuing
reimposition of constraints over the
last
year because we are so used to this new
dynamic but um we've all been doing this
newspaper review at really dark moments
you know when the lockdown
another lockdown was being imposed when
it was quite clear that
boris johnson was being wholly
prematurely
optimistic but this feels as if there is
real cause for optimism i mean virtually
every front page
has optimistic headlines about emerging
more fully out of a lockdown in may and
then again in june
and we've got the evidence for it the
vaccines seem to be working
with the qualification about variants
and no one knows for sure the impact of
opening up on this
scale but there is a really positive
mood
that perhaps perhaps we are moving
towards
the end of lockdowns yes qualification
about variants but also modelling which
has been repeated by
sage and its subcommittees tonight about
the possibility of an increase in cases
which can very quickly go exponential
we've seen ourselves with the kent
variant
we're seeing it in india now um you know
sort of beginning to have warnings about
august and september you know i don't
know what the government does now to
keep a lid on it having said this is
going to be the last lockdown
whether there be any appetite selma to
ever go back into
any other form of restrictions um it
leaves them in
in something of a quandary doesn't it
well it does except for the fact that
they have international
examples where they could actually uh
look to so new zealand for example
sort of thought about its domestic
opening over and above its international
opening
and i think um as far as a lot of
businesses are concerned service
businesses
they can still operate um you know
whilst being open
but obviously hospitality can't so it's
about sort of dealing with that before
you start looking at other sectors like
uh travel and tourism that are going to
be hit so i think
the government sort of assessment is
going to have to look at what they can
keep
open even if you get some kind of like
exponential
growth which means that you can control
it
so one of the big issues that many
people have talked about today makes the
front page of the
eye six days until you can hug your
family
that word hug sort of symbolizes the
strange position we've been in
where the government can tell us what to
do about something
that basic something so human and
it's a very strange thing that somebody
can now tell me in six days i'm allowed
to do something like that steve
yeah and it's kind of up to us you know
who you decide to
hug or not as the case may be you know
in france i've always wondered
how they choose you know you can use vu
which is very kind of formal
and two when you are being a bit
intimate with people
and i always wondered how they chose
well now we're gonna
have to decide ourselves who to hug and
it could
involve all kinds of embarrassing
moments you know i can imagine
moving towards embracing someone and
being horrified if they move away you
know what i mean
we're all going to experience these
things but it's over to us
now um we've been told not to do this
um my guess is there will be a lot of
hugging to be honest
you know people would just do it
indiscriminately for a bit
um but johnson says still be cautious
and i think he's right and i'm pleased
you mentioned that the scientists are
still
really looking at this carefully looking
at the consequences
but as i said at the beginning that does
seem to be because of the vaccines
more substance for this current wave of
hugging
optimism yes uh daily telegraph picks up
on that
idea of common sense which it's not the
first time boris johnson has used that
that phrase there has been a suggestion
that everybody's doing something which
is one step ahead of where the
government allows us to that people are
probably
already meeting indoors even if they've
got their back door open
do you think that's fair or do you think
people have still been really well
behaved
selma so i mean based on the figures and
given the fact that the
um viruses obviously decreasing quite
significantly here
you would expect there to be a high
level of compliance and
i think anybody who's making these kinds
of decisions
would accept that some people are going
to bend the rules a little bit
um but i think that the idea of common
sense
given that people have all become real
experts in in
covert and covert practices means that
people are going to take that risk
assessment themselves and the government
really can't do that for everybody
on a personal level before i hug anyone
i'm going to make sure that i see their
vaccine certification
um before i make contact i'm not going
to be as fast
as steve
yes well we do i won't ask you the
question which was put to the prime
minister who you're going to hug
or hug first we'll just leave that there
you don't you know you don't want to
make people too unhappy do you
um but there is such a range of things
that people can do
and it is the indoor bit which the
scientists are concerned about
but really economically this is
absolutely vital isn't it for
the hospitality sector and others steve
yeah i mean it is still strange going
into central london and seeing
everything
close and obviously some people sitting
outside but a lot of those restaurants
can't have
that kind of outside space and so are
lying
empty dark and it is
urgent for them to reopen and allow
people
inside and and i think that if assuming
it happens and it goes
smoothly i mean we had a disaster last
summer with all that
eat out to help out stuff but assuming
this time
with the vaccine it's safe yeah it's
going to be a massive
boost to that sector which has been so
badly hit
by what's happened over the last year
and it'll be a good boost for everybody
i think everybody wants to get out
and do things almost you know i think as
we were talking earlier would be
awareness in some places
um so it's a double winner
assuming it works this time yes the list
um
hopefully on the on the front page of
the telegraph cinemas i mean who's been
to one of those for as long as we can
remember theaters
museums concert halls business
conference centers
not to mention hotels uh b and b's
that's what you're talking about getting
out isn't it doing
new things which takes us in some
respects salma darei to the
the sun which is this strange situation
that if you've been
well if you've been going out with
somebody you've not been able to stay
overnight
um yet another thing like the hug that
you're being told by
central government that you can and
can't do
well i think if you have been going out
with someone
that i think very early on there was a
uh some advice from the
deputy um chief medical officer that was
like you know maybe this is the time to
think about the solidity of your
relationship and maybe
create a bubble together i think the
sun's um
front page is really interesting because
it's a lot more about
those sort of um random meetings that
you have and those random interactions
and uh it seems as the sun is quite
eloquently laid out i think
uh that the next range of um openings is
going to
be about having that first date and
obviously ending in some success by the
end of it
i don't really want to go there
personally i know it's late and all that
but
about hugging seems so innocent compared
with those
yeah let's just let's just stop at the
heart shall we
and just one final thought this idea of
with the vaccination program
um i see it's been reported that the fda
is approving the fisa vaccine for 12 to
15 year olds in america
this idea that we're still going to
vaccinate younger and younger people
as we go down the cohorts but but is
there a sense that the vaccine
will win the day and and this is kind of
over or the worst of it's over steve
should we feel optimistic do you think
well yeah i mean this calls for optimism
has been the theme of this
paper review with that qualification of
variance of unpredicted with
unpredictable
consequences and even at the press
conference today the scientists you know
the number 10 press conference
the scientists were expressing quite a
lot of caution about
some one of the latest variants that has
emerged so that is a really big
qualification
but you know as we've been saying all
the way through with the vaccines
there is evidence that it's really i
think were there no deaths recorded
today
i mean there's it seems to be working
for now
just in england that was actually um
that was the case yeah that was england
not the uk overall but yes i mean you
know extraordinary
given where we've come from and given
what is still happening
in nations like uh india and elsewhere
so
you know we watch with caution around
the world don't we um but fingers
crossed certainly a positive set of
newspapers certainly if you're uh
you're in downey street well welcome
back you're watching the press preview
with me now steve richards and salma
shah
we've reflected on the the covert
opening up but uh
tomorrow's queen's speech will be under
covered pandemic restrictions steve
won't it
first time also we see the queen in such
a a big role since the death
of of her husband as well so it's going
to be a a strange old day in some
respects
it will be strange but i still think it
would be quite significant
politically very easy for boris johnson
he's had the high of the hartlepool
by-election and other gains but quite a
big test for kierstama
uh he'll be speaking in the queen's
speech debate as well
and has come under severe criticism not
just from
one section of his party but quite a few
across the whole spectrum have been
highly critical so this is his first
public test since that whole
shadow cabinet uh furore over the
weekend
um so it'd be significant in that but as
the metro indicates in other papers
there will be propositions with quite a
lot of consequences
in the legislative program so just very
quickly what would you what would you
like us to watch out for then
well for example samara i've talked
about in the break
uh the end of that fixed term parliament
act introduced by cameron and the
coalition for certain i think
self-interested
reasons and for similarly
self-interested reasons
uh boris johnson wants the flexibility
to call an election
without any of those constraints but
there are many other
interesting bills uh some of which will
be difficult to implement and deliver
yes it's always such a big day isn't it
um angela rayne has been speaking in the
guardian salma
labour has talked down to voters for too
long while the
ft is talking about boris johnson's
holiday to mustique
despite the fact that many have
suggested that the voters indicated they
weren't that bothered about
wallpaper costs or otherwise
yeah i think the interesting thing about
the johnson holiday actually
there's two interesting things about it
one is that just because people don't
care it doesn't mean that it doesn't
matter and i think it's important that
you have the standards commissioner
looking at something like this
uh because it is about sort of who has
access to the prime minister
and who is providing the prime minister
with um
you know grace and favor kind of
holidays so that is important and it's
and it's right that it should be
investigated properly
i think um on the other side of it is
that um
we have to wait and see sort of what the
consequences of this are actually going
to be because
number 10 have actually been quite
robust about the line in defending
the transparency around this holiday
so um hopefully i mean from my
perspective
it is something that is something akin
to an administrative oversight
uh but we'll wait to see what happens
there with um angela rayna i think it's
very interesting
given the fact that she's been
reshuffled out of uh you know a
significant job of campaigning
that she is still talking about work the
working class
in this way and i think that labor to a
certain extent has slightly fetishized
the working classes some people call it
patronizing and i think
part of this message still really sticks
to that
idea that um most people find
you know doesn't really suit them or
their identity
so whilst other people are thinking
about themselves as aspirational i think
the labour party have a real problem in
categorizing this group of people that
they've now lost
yeah that's interesting isn't it and
just in the last 20 seconds steve um
goodbye fixed term parliament act less
time possibly
for labour to get his act together
possibly um yeah i certainly in 2023
he's way ahead in the polls johnson he
will be very tempted to find an excuse
to
call an election it's still more likely
when this fixed on parliament wasn't in
place and prime ministers had a choice
they still tended to go four or five
years
rather than three those who went early
tended to lose
so it's not a guarantee um but yeah it
becomes a bigger possibility in the
light of this change
yeah but with talk of indie ref two and
an early election
we can't cope can we i think we've had
so many yeah
yes steve we'll see at half eleven thank
you